grab your Scrabble pieces to play with
grandpa because we're off to Christmas
land what yes the first season of AMC's
latest horror show Nosferatu has come to
an end and has already been renewed for
season two so in this video we're gonna
be taking a deep dive into the ending
and what it could mean for next season
the final episode begins with our
protagonist Vic McQueen escaping Charlie
minx's aptly named slay house which is
also the title of episode 9 and can be
found in green graffiti on Vic's bridge
Charlie had previously wanted to bring
Vic to Christmas lands so she could be a
mother for all the children there but
why Vic what makes her so special Vic is
what's called a strong creative someone
who's able to pull their enscape into
the real world
but hold on things story what the hell
is an inscape in episode 2 Vic meets
Maggie and orphan medium who also has a
magical bag of Scrabble pieces which can
answer any question well almost any
we'll get to that in a bit
Maggie was foretold that a strong
creative named the brat would soon meet
up with her and the Brad is Vic's
father's nickname for her she explains
how strong creatives work and there are
two key terms to know the knife and the
inscape the inscape is what strong
creatives used to essentially bridge a
gap between the real world and the
imaginary and for Vic her inscape is a
literal bridge for example when we later
meet Jolene July Charlie's first lover
who he wanted to make the mother of
Christmas land we find out her inscape
is the dark tunnels a strong creatives
enscape and its subsequent ability is
also shaped by who the person
controlling it is when Charlie senses
the presence of another strong creative
he's won himself he comes across her
enscape a dilapidated old bridge and
surmises that its owner is someone who
has a strong attachment to something
broken
aka her family which is why the bridge
looks worn out our strong creative has
no soul and a sentimental attachment to
broken things but it's also someone who
longs to escape their circumstances the
bridge symbolizing a means to get away
something Vic does several times
throughout the episode this bridge also
tells us we're looking for someone who
likes to
traverse geographical locations who
perhaps longs to escape their
circumstances but using one's enscape
comes at a price for Vick it takes a
physical toll she experiences headaches
nausea and bloody eyes so using it as
many times as she wants is out of the
question another unique aspect of in
escapes is that they can be used to
transport others not just the strong
creative who conjures them for example
Joe brings Vic into the dark tunnels and
Charlie brings the children to Christmas
land but in escapes require one key
component in order to work what Maggie
calls a knife because knives cut the
fabric between the real world and the
world of thought they are the devices
which allow you access to your inscape
and escape itself world dreams up in
your imagination everybody has them but
only strong creatives can pull theirs
into the real world with the help of a
knife for Vic
it's a motorbike for Joe it's her roller
skates and for Charlie it's his
rolls-royce dubbed the Wraith without
ones knife you can't access your enscape
which is why when Charlie throws her
motorcycle into her inscape she believes
it to be gone for good how can she get
into her enscape when the thing that
allows her to access it is gone but if
there's one thing we've learned from
Jolene is that knives can manifest
themselves in different ways to
accommodate the physical limits of their
creative I didn't know you could have
more than one I thought my dirtbike was
it I thought to say when Joe was young
her knife were her roller skates but as
she grew old she couldn't muster the
speed to travel any more but one day a
new knife came to her a wheelchair
before she too couldn't handle that it's
only until Vic comes along that she's
able to push her wheelchair fast enough
in order to access her inscape Jolene's
ability is also different from Vic's
Jolene is able to essentially spy on
anyone of course when they spy on
Charlie he notices it he can sense the
power of strong creatives
actually
it's in this scene that Vik learns
Charlie's power is linked to the Wraith
when Jolene overheats the engine Charlie
melts from his younger form into an old
man we see this happen in the final
episode when Vic uses gas to burn the
Wraith and Charlie's physical form melts
along with it but burning the Wraith had
its consequences in the backseat was
Vic's lover Craig who she couldn't save
due to this barrier which only Charlie
could bring people in and out of it was
the price Vic had to pay in order to
stop Charlie but as will later find out
the car was not fully destroyed in the
last scene of the season we see a
mechanic starting to work on the burnt
to a crisp rolls-royce as he jumped
starts the car so too does Charlie
scaring the daylights out of a nurse who
was prepping him for a blood transfusion
and it's fitting that one of the final
shots is of this blood since the show's
name is not only allusion to Charlie's
license plate but also the vampire
Nosferatu also a being which could live
forever one of the more shocking
revelations was Vic's pregnancy and for
a girl who wants nothing more than to
leave Haverhill this puts a huge wrench
in things Vic starts off the season
wanting nothing more than to attend RISD
the Rhode Island School of Design she's
not shy in expressing her thoughts about
Haverhill either for Victor's two
options leave town or stay and get
knocked up and start a family she's seen
what the latter option has done to her
parents her dad is an abusive alcoholic
and her mom doesn't support her decision
to leave if her mom had it her way she'd
worked the rest of her life cleaning
homes making an honest wage rather than
trekking out to the city to be a
starving artist her dad on the other
hand believes in her but also happens to
be an alcoholic who has to ice his hands
from smacking around mom so much he
knocked her up when he was young and had
to put his music career aside something
I'm sure he resents her for I thought
that I was gonna go to like a real music
school service expensive
I need to get a job couldn't do it
regardless Vic is the most important
thing in his life and over the course of
the season we see him fail at being a
father countless times but in the end he
makes his biggest sacrifice
by giving up drinking in order to get
closer with his daughter Vic also goes
through the change of being the
reluctant hero when she's first
approached by Maggie she pleads to her
you are the only person that can stop
him ok the girl finds lost things can
find lost children don't you see you've
been chosen but Vic doesn't want this
responsibility it's only until Hayley's
kidnapping and the death of Hayley's
mother that Vic realizes Charley must be
stopped for good and her powers are the
only ones that can stop it Vic is able
to find lost things using her enscape
like her father's watch Craig's
childhood bunny and even people if she
could somehow harness her power to find
Christmas land perhaps she could find
the children and that's a huge question
mark for the season with Charlie taken
care of where are the kids
and is there even a Christmas land
anymore Maggie tells Vic that she
consulted the Scrabble pieces and for
the first time at least that we know of
they come out blank but it's safe to say
that this isn't the last we've heard of
Christmas land especially with this
season 2 on the way in the books the
story fast for it's 12 years from the
events of the gas station where Vic is
constantly haunted by the voices of the
vampire children they're pissed at what
she's done to their father Charlie we
get a hint of this when Vic is seen
outside Charlie's burned down house also
visibly pregnant my best guess for next
season is that the show will follow a
similar time jump one in which Charlie
has recovered and Vic is now raising a
young child we know that Charlie
collects children from parents who he
has deemed naughty and with him seeing
Vic as impure after he found out she
slept with Craig it's pretty much
guaranteed he's going to come after her
child but what of the other children at
Christmas land can they be saved
according to the books yes in fact they
later find out that by smashing the
ornaments you can return a vampire child
back to its human form but there was an
alternate ending in which some of the
ornaments survived and the vampires
somehow make it into the real world so
if this is a show that goes beyond two
seasons it will have to expand outside
of Christmas land and Haverhill there's
also the question of being who is one of
my favorite characters
the show beings goal in life was to get
to Christmas land where there's nothing
but joy and happiness something here on
eclis found in a comic Vic gave him
being is so taken aback by Christmas
land he writes a letter to the CEO and
founder of Christmas land on a manual
typewriter no less that he would do
anything to get there
that's when Charlie recruits him as the
new chief of security since the old one
was killed by Charlie for botching the
kidnapping of Danny the young boy from
episode 1 Bing is the perfect loyal
henchman easy to manipulate and spurred
by childhood trauma being himself was
treated cruelly by his father so he
knows what it's like for a child to be
abused his father gave him a gas mask as
a Christmas present when he was a child
a hand-me-down from his days in Nam and
chemical attacks Bing would later go on
to use this mask when gassing his
victims gasps he acquired from his job
and it's fun to see being having evaded
the police at the end of the season now
known only as mr. Anderson having shaved
his beard he's found employment at a
dentist's office where he'll have easy
access to more toxic gases and can
dispense candy to young children it's
also worth mentioning the final episodes
introduction of Lou Carmody in the books
he's the one to impregnate Vic and they
called their son Bruce Wayne Carmody
we already know from this episode Lou's
affinity for comic books he even goes on
to tell Vic that she's a superhero like
a superhero but my guess is that the
show will deviate from this and make Lou
more of a father figure to this new kid
allowing Vic to explore other
relationships if any in season 2 we also
have Maggie and detective hunter now
that hunter knows the power of Maggie's
Scrabble bag it's easy to assume that
hunter will be calling on her help with
cases along the way as for RISD well I
think Vic will have to put her child
before school just like her dad put her
career on hold for her but one thing is
for certain
as Charlie regains his power Vic will
need to get her knife back and because
Jolene told us that knives can manifest
in new ways I wouldn't be surprised if a
new motorcycle or something completely
different appears for Vic so she can use
it against Charlie that's it for this
video guys I want to know what you
thought about the season in the comments
below and also make sure to LIKE and
subscribe you can follow me on twitter
at things story whitey and
next time remember daddy loves you very
much
[Music]